we've not heard from Pat Robertson for a
little while so I should just reset and
remind you about Pat Robertson he's the
televangelists who hosts the 700 club
it's produced by the Christian
Broadcasting Network Pat Robertson is
called many many things demonic over
time feng shui Ouija boards yoga karate
horoscopes Twilight books and movies
paintings of Buddha television shows
about ghosts
psychics young girls levitating their
friends when they have sleepovers
sometimes even adopted children from
other countries or sweaters that you get
from good will can be demonic and it
could have demons attached to them but
of course one of the most popular
demonic allegations we hear from Pat
Robertson and his ilk are about
Halloween we're only about a month from
Halloween and Pat Robertson is I guess
really getting into the Halloween spirit
hello Halloween is an interesting season
for right wing TV Christians during
Halloween people like Pat Robertson
forget about criticizing Muslims
atheists and Jews and instead just focus
on Halloween and I've got a really funny
new clip from the 700 club this was I
believe yesterday or a couple days ago
where someone wrote in concerned about
their son I believe it is participating
in Halloween celebrations I'm not even
going to tell you what Pat Robertson
says I'll just play it for you and then
we'll we'll analyze afterwards this next
one is from Diane who says every year I
let my teenage son go with friends to a
Halloween event at a local theme park I
just learned that they have a haunted
house based on Satan and demons
apparently there are girls and
suggestive demon outfits selling drinks
techno music and even a demon DJ who
encourages people to dance how dare you
I know my son is a good boy and he will
be disappointed if I don't let him go
how can I make him understand that
keeping him away is the best thing for
him well you got to tell him the truth I
mean explain to him who the devil is
explained to him the devil wants to
destroy you the devil you know seeks who
he may devour he's out to kill you and
he's going to put everything nice in
your weight it's gonna seem like fondest
pleasure and sin for a season but the
answer is mother don't let your babies
grow up to be demon worshippers if I can
quote from Willie Nelson
yeah don't don't let them do it I mean
you know that's just the way it is and
you say look no I'm sorry or better than
that they need to be alternative
Halloween celebrations in churches where
they have all the games and all the fun
and all the nice pretty girls and all
the handsome boys and all that they all
come together and they're praising the
Lord instead of worshipping Satan with
how Elaine has become a knight when the
devil rejoices all right yeah Halloween
at a church now that sounds like a party
right Halloween encourages people to
dance that is very very dangerous have
you heard about twerking it's insane
what can happen when that goes on it's
fascinating to me how these extremist
Christians get completely opened over
over the top up in arms because of these
imaginary characters right everybody
from Harry Potter to the devil gets
these guys up in arms
I actually remember some kids in
elementary school whose parents forbid
them from trick-or-treating for
religious reasons I think there was one
I guess what you would call standard
Christian and then a few of the most of
the kids who were banned from
trick-or-treating were actually
jehovah's witnesses which I know are
there's debate over whether they're
Christians or not I mean certainly Jesus
is part of their religion so I say that
they are Christians and they were also
banned from celebrating their birthdays
which it really kind of sounded like a
sad upbringing if I'm completely honest
with you here depending on who you are
in the u.s. or your economic status or
whether you're acting under the name of
religion or not ideas like Halloween is
Satan worship either get you a national
TV show on the Christian Broadcasting
Network or they get you an involuntary
stay at a psych ward it's very very
interesting how the ideas that are
either considered legitimate religious
ideas or ideas for which you need to be
medicated are really not that different
than if anybody's ever been proof of
that it is Pat Robertson